welcome everybody
this is a special occasion for me to
greet someone who is on every list of
the most powerful women in the world and
someone who belongs to us here at Els om
and has from the very beginning belonged
to us I would say not just because she
went here but because in so many ways in
every speech he gives and in every time
you see her spotlighted I can just hear
the som name
exuding from her and I think we'll see
some of that today what we're going to
do is have a conversation so I'm gonna
ask some questions and she's going to
give some answers and and then at the
end we'll probably have a question time
for one or two questions from the
audience as well and hopefully we won't
wander too far off the kinds of topics
you'd like to hear so Indra
when I was in LA saw you we were in
India and one of the things that you
spoke about and several of your leaders
spoke about was your performance with
purpose program and I was very taken by
it and actually came back and we run a
Leadership Development Program class and
spoke with it to my class because for me
it resonated again with the som
leadership model the model of what it is
we do so I wonder if we could start
there can you talk a little bit about
what you mean by performance with
purpose what's special about it and then
put a plug in maybe for having comes
from your som good
not to leader I wouldn't call it a
movement performance with purpose is how
we run the company and to really
understand the genesis of performance of
purpose and what is done for the company
should go back a bit I became CEO in
October of 2006 and I strongly believed
then as I do now that all corporations
operate from a license with the license
from society we're all limited liability
companies and the reason we have limited
liabilities because Society gives us a
license to operate and because we have
the license to operate real society a
duty of care which means that if you
operate in a society you have to worry
about the costs that you are the company
are imposing on society and it is not
right to think of your P&L as revenues
less your own costs and that's your
profit it's really revenues less cost
less cost to society that's the real
profit because you can't toss costs onto
taxpayers so if you start with that as a
notion of the enterprise you have to
start thinking about what can you do to
reduce those costs that you pass on to
society ok and nobody's going to
calculate that for you and tell you
exactly what it is it's what you feel
and the reason it's important to think
that way is because all the employees in
PepsiCo are first
mother's father's children husbands
wives on samples before they are
employees of PepsiCo and the only way
that we thought we'd get the best and
brightest to come at work at PepsiCo is
if we allowed themselves to bring their
whole selves to work not park themselves
at the door and walk in and be somebody
else so we had to think about how we
articulate the direction of the company
in a way that makes everybody feel very
good about the company not because of
our financial performance alone although
that's necessary but in terms of the
holistic impact we have in society so
the question was how can we deliver
performance with purpose and our defined
purpose for you such that taken together
performance cannot be delivered with
that purpose and purpose leads to
performance so the way we define purpose
was
in three planks the first is the whole
notion of a human sustainability no
we're in the business of food and
beverage we feed people how do we make
sure that our portfolio which tended to
be all fun for your products also gave
people a choice to have highly
nutritious great tasting products and
even for the fun for your products how
do you reduce the sugar levels the fat
levels sodium levels how do you do that
so we took upon ourselves an explicit
goal to start altering the portfolio but
not just words we said goals milestones
we hired a new R&D team we put it in
everybody's performance appraisal so
that was the first plank now as I said
to you earlier if we didn't transform
the portfolio people wouldn't consume as
many products because society was
changing so you needed to transform the
portfolio to deliver performance so the
first was how do you make sure of
healthier people and while you transform
the portfolio how do you work with
communities to put physical education
back in schools how do you improve
calorie labeling nutrition education all
of that was part of that human
sustainability plank
the second was environmental
sustainability how do you make sure that
our operations don't do bad things for
the environment
water reduction energy stepping up
recycling in a massive way all of that
again and within that with the
communities how do you make sure that
you only focus on sustainable
agriculture because we buy potatoes we
buy corn we buy oranges we buy oats how
do you make sure in every country in
which you operate you operate
responsibly with agriculture and the
third part of purpose was something that
I put in felt very strongly about it is
how do you create an environment where
our people feel like they can bring
their whole selves to work so that you
can come to PepsiCo and not just make a
living but have a life that was the
whole concept and unless you have great
people you can't deliver performance so
performance with purpose was about doing
good by doing good and taken together
what it is done for PepsiCo is is
unleashed the emotions of everybody in
the company and for those of you who've
seen the new Pepsi Refresh project and
if you haven't please go to refresh
everything calm and see what they've
done it's not a plug for a Prada
because it's a campaign to give grants
to communities instead of spending it on
an advertising campaign for Pepsi that
to me takes performance and purpose to a
whole new level and says performances
purpose is not corporate social
responsibility performance with purpose
is about how you can intimately linked
what a company can do with what the
needs of society are and together
deliver great performance and coming
back to som I think som self-selects
great students and I think som select
students have got a soul we've got a
deep it is they did who have a deep
sense of community country want to give
back and I think what you learned in
there so I'm you're carried through as
you leave as a well we still have those
same students I always say we have
students with hearts and minds
absolutely and I think that's always
been true from the absolutely Andrew you
mentioned briefly the the nutrition
obesity program and I remember again
when I was with you and purchase we
talked a little bit about the difficulty
of taking on your critics so here's a
situation in which your whole industry's
been criticized on nutritional grounds
on sugar salt or whatever you want and
you've chosen to work with those critics
can you talk a little bit about the
challenges associated with that well how
you came to think about doing it this
way it's very different from most of
your other CEO is in similar areas see
when the critic started about you know
sugared beverages or salty snacks the
first reaction of any CEO it was of me
to say you're stupid because obesity is
a multi-faceted problem you've got to
worry about calories and calories out I
mean the usual guns come out and that's
how most CEOs in our industry spoke
about this issue but then we stepped
back and said wait a minute let's walk a
mile in the shoes of the critics so
that's one of the rules we have in all
of PepsiCo anybody who criticizes us
let's walk a mile in their shoes to
understand if we were that critic
we were that NGO how would we approach
PepsiCo and then figure out how to work
with them to evolve a good solution so
when we sat down and talked to each of
our critics including Kelly Brownell
who's right here at the Yale rad Center
who actually is a critic but a
responsible critic because a lot of
critics have the bully pulpit but are
not responsible okay but Kelly is a very
responsible critic and his point was
look society has changed there's nothing
wrong with the products but those were
products for a different time and how do
you get people to have this notion of
balance I mean this is about balance in
your lifestyle I mean for those of you
have had a cold Pepsi it's to die for
okay but the fact of the matter is the
fact the fact of the matter is nobody
asked you to drink of cold Pepsi sitting
in front of a TV and not exercising
nobody asked you to do that okay but in
today's world and today's sedentary
lifestyles that's what people do and
then they say oh it's because of the
Pepsi I'll say it's because of cable TVs
because of the computer all of that is
stupid this is not about the blame game
the question is we as a company that
provides food and beverages can provide
some solutions what solutions can we
provide we can increase advertising on
Diet Pepsi we can reduce the sugar and
regular Pepsi itself without sacrificing
taste with some breakthrough we can
advertise asking people to get up and
move we can improve nutrition education
so all of that's right for society again
going back to cost to society so as a
company we engage with all the critics
and we say tell you what let us take on
action items to actually make a
difference and so we do not criticize
the critics we actually talk to every
one of them you know Michael Jacobson
and the Center for Science and public
interest was a very outspoken critic
Kerry Brown on any of these people we
actually talk with them sometimes we
agree sometimes we violently disagree
but at least we've listened to their
point of view but I will tell you one
thing I think a couple of years ago at a
shareholder meeting one of the water
critics came and you know they usually
come in large numbers to the shareholder
meetings and the usually come with boxes
of letters from their constituents
criticizing the company's behavior so
they brought me I think 25
ladies in a box and I took the lettuce I
read a few of them quickly before the
meeting then they online up those of you
VIN and shareholder meetings free
question-and-answer time anybody can
line up at the microphone and ask to see
e or any question so they line up all of
their all the water critics and they
tell me about water scarcity water
shortage I listen to them of about three
minutes and I look to them and said how
many of you have grown up in a water
shortage environment not one of them I
said I have so let me tell you how I
approach water shortage I feel it even
you might talk about it I feel it and
let me tell you what PepsiCo is doing
about it and for the next 10 minutes I
talked about what it is to grow with
water shortage and why I feel strongly
that we need to do something and we are
doing something since then they have
been our best partners in working with
us to address this issue of water you
know replenishment and making sure that
there's water efficiency so I think when
you engage with critics when you're
sincere about a dialogue they too are
willing to play ball with you as opposed
to you fight back at them and they get
more belligerent and more antagonistic
surely some are suspicious though Indra
yeah and what do you do then I mean
surely some people listen to you and
think oh sure she's running you know
this big company she's good on her feet
but I don't really trust it what do you
do coming work at PepsiCo and see for
yourself there are two PepsiCo one Megan
you worked an environmental
sustainability you should stand ask her
you know actually I tell you you're
absolutely right and being suspicious
and you should be I would be too if I
didn't work for PepsiCo I didn't leaders
but at the end of the day the proof of
the pudding is in the eating in today's
world in particular where everything has
to be transparent we're a sustainability
report has to be approved by auditors
and published you have to look at that
whole track record but let me also say
something Sharon what do you gain by
being suspicious yeah okay I'd start off
saying big companies are in fact good
because they drive innovation they
provide jobs they're engine for growth
so let's figure out how to work with big
companies to make a difference as
opposed to you know sounding like a
communist and saying big companies are
bad you know we need to go to
state-owned enterprises doesn't work
state-owned enterprises are the biggest
polluters let's not forget it so I think
we should start with trust because in
today's world I'm talking about Main
Street I'm not talking about anything
else that caused the financial crisis
I'm talking about good Main Street that
the preponderance of companies are doing
just fine and look at them and say if
you don't work constructively with them
how are we gonna solve the problems of
the world so be suspicious but you know
though spend that much time on that
suspicion right I think that's great to
show other people that being a partner
is going to be useful to them as well I
think it's a great way to go so Andres
the leaders forum hmm and you know you
are again on every list of the great
women leaders can you tell us a little
bit about challenges that you face in
leadership what's your how do you
characterize your style of leadership
our women leader is different from men
leaders how are you different from other
leaders you see you spend a lot of time
at places like Jeff Simon fellas see
Seelye operation watch and have the rest
of the guys behave and tell us a little
bit about what's what's different what
you do well and not so well how you
think about leadership you know until
you
somebody said to me there are more books
written about leadership than any other
topic every every person from movie
stars to CEOs to presidents have written
books on leadership I think leadership
is a very personal thing so there are
many definitions of leadership assume
that every definition is right because
you know depends on your perspective
from a personal perspective I tell you
leaders especially CEOs have to get an
entire organization to do things they
never thought they needed to do because
you see a future before anybody else
sees it so it's almost on paper it's
impossible to be an effective CEO but
every CEO that I talk to so I'm not
unusual in this is always looking around
the bend and seeing things that the rest
of the organization has not seen and
then you have to educate the rest of the
organization and they need to drag them
to come along and it's even worse when
the company is doing well because they
are save it ain't broke why fix it and
you go because it's gonna break how do
you know how do you know trust me it's
gonna break and so that's the worst
message because turning around a
successful company is harder than having
a burning platform that's one thing
because when you're running a successful
company they go what's wrong with the
why she articulating a burning platform
and there isn't one so in our case I'll
tell you being a CEO running a
successful company has been the biggest
problem because you've been constantly
going to tell people you've got to
reinvent ourselves people go put our
playbook was just fine why do we have to
reinvent ourselves because that playbook
is gonna become obsolete in 12 months
how do you know trust me the following
10 reasons yeah but I can give you five
other reasons why that's not the case
and so a CEO has to lead with the head
laying on all these scenarios with your
heart you have got to show passion for
the business the people you've got to
treat each person as if they were the
most important person in that company
especially a direct reports you've got a
overdo the caring and feeding of those
people and with your hands so your head
heart and hands you've got to lead the
company with all of that you've got to
do you can't just talk you can't just
give speeches you've got to demonstrate
the change can happen you know jump in
and get into the details if it's so
requires from a female versus male
perspective I don't even I don't even
know how to characterize my leadership
style because I think over the years
it's evolved and depending on the people
that work with me I have to evolve my
leadership style and to me that's the
most difficult thing because there isn't
a cookbook that says here's the way to
run a forty billion dollar company he
has a sixty billion dollar company
picked the book with sixty billion
dollars and just read the chapters maybe
Jeff you can write one but there but
there but there isn't one so you're
writing the rules as you go along
because we used to be 43 billion in a
few days we're gonna be sixty billion
how do you make this transition to go
from 150 thousand employees to three
hundred thousand employees how do you
all of a sudden take on that much more
responsibility and you're the same
person so you have to evolve as you go
along and for women in particular it's
harder because we are sort of a victim
of our own gender
we have antennae that sticks out says I
was talking to the women and management
group when I see guys and guys dealing
with each other
when a man is a CEO and he has been
working for him and the man walks him
down and has something on his mind
the man CEO just blows by and says I
need the following three things done in
my case my antenna comes out it shut the
door go what's the matter
tell me about it and all of a sudden I'm
drawn into the individuals issues and
concerns and worries as opposed to
saying Oh grow up you're all
professionals so I think women CEOs at
least it just about me I cannot nothing
can be generalized some of us who rule
with a head heart and hand but with hot
head in hand you know put that high
before the head and hands like I do we
spend a disproportionate amount of time
at work with the people that's good and
bad because it evokes a lot of
commitment but the baddest it's a lot of
time I'll give you one particular story
and this is one I'd like you guys to
take
as you go to work about two years ago I
started to write to parents of my direct
reports okay and it happened because you
know I am Indian origin and I was in
India and my father passed with many
many years ago my mom lives in India and
I went home to spend time with her and
every two minutes some stranger would
show up home and my mom would say this
is the neighbors fourth cousin come and
say hello and I say mom I'm here on
vacation I want to rest and she'd say
you may come here for four days and
leave but I have to live with these
people so you better show up and be on
display so I was dressed you don't like
I was going to a party morning to
evening just to say hello to people but
the irony of it was they would come in
they say oh so this is the daughter and
then they blow past me in 30 seconds and
go to my mom and say you are so
wonderful you gave birth to this child
it's you that's great so her mom would
just sit there take it all these
compliments at that point and you know
she's a very humble woman but she loved
this so at that time it occurred to me
that every person is you know product or
a victim of the Rob bringing so I came
back and I said look I have at that time
I between my direct reports and one more
level 27 of them I said all of these
people who run PepsiCo are in fact the
products of the upbringing so I owe
their parents
I thank you so I wrote to every one of
the parents a standard paragraph
explaining why I was writing to them and
I wrote very tailored two or three
paragraphs about their son or daughter
thanking them for the gift of their
child to PepsiCo the emotion that is
evoked has been unbelievable and I write
to them now once a year since then but
the emotion is evoked is unbelievable
they come and they write me notes dear
Indra I just went to the store I saw
this maybe you should talk to my son too
it is this private dialogue they write
to me about everything
I saw your squawk box I loved what you
said bless you I went to church and said
a prayer for you you know what it's a
private dialogue I have a parents and I
think it's it it increases the
commitment of the executives to PepsiCo
because it's brought the whole family we
always wrote the spouses that's a
PepsiCo tradition but now we brought the
parents in and I say this to you because
remember I talked to you about ruling
the company with hot head and hands this
is the hot pot and it takes more time I
also made a commitment which I think may
have been a mistake but I committed that
I would visit every one of those parents
so out of my 16 direct reports I've done
ten I still have six to go but they're
not in the most readily accessible
places but I'll get it done it was worth
it
wait'll I start writing to your parents
since my son left high school I haven't
had a report card today I would say
they're probably not many male CEOs who
were writing to people's parents and I
think I don't you now beginning to I
tell them stories and asking them to
write and I'm finding that some of the
people that I've shared the story with
have now begun to write and they call me
back and say I cannot believe what's
done what is done to my people one CEO
said to me that his son was estranged
from his dad for 26 years but after his
dad got this letter the dad came to the
office and they put the Sun on the dad
back together so it's really it's done
wonderful things and it's certainly
consistent with the whole person didn't
tell us about bringing a whole person
the whole person is really that's a
constellation of other whole people
attend to them so enrich as you look
around I'm sure you've noticed that and
talked to some of the people ahead of
time our students come from all over the
world I seem to recall that your first
real time of any length
in America was here at the L som can you
talk a little bit about how it was when
you first arrived here as as someone
from a different culture and how you
found it and and just how it was and how
you reflect upon it now as a grownup
been around the world for many years and
living many place I think yield then and
yield now som dinner yes I saw him now
very different places you know I was in
som I was a third group to go through
restaurant I graduated in 1980 long long
long long time ago and didn't have the
amount of support systems that we have
today Yale was known as diverse as it is
today then have as many women
international students I mean none of
those support systems existed so it was
a pretty lonely place but there were
three women in the admissions office Pat
Porter soon and three of them that he
was a German nurse yeah I can see a
family too for the three of them the
three of them decided they would take me
under their wing and it was just
unbelievable the rest of year there were
no support systems but Pat sue and Anna
I think the three of them said we'll
take you under our wing and every day in
the morning when I used to be down just
go to them and they would be my three
moms and you know take good care of me
and then the cutest thing is how they
went around New Haven looking for that
Indian family that could feed me because
I was a vegetarian and they found these
families that would send me care
packages right this is the kind of
health that I got you could have learned
to cook injure that
believe it or not I lived in Hall of
Graduate Studies
there was no kitchen facilities a month
later I moved to hadlen but you know
when you're working late
sadly I was the official cook for the
group so if I didn't cook the rest of my
group didn't eat so I was the official
poster that's a sad part but you know
here's a sad thing at that time I didn't
have money you know at the end the end
of the month if I saved $5 I thought I'd
died and gone to heaven
okay so totally and completely broke is
the one no money to buy clothes nothing
absolutely nothing so I've worked the
front desk of Hadley Hall from midnight
to 5:00 a.m. and it paid 3:35 that time
that was the minimum wage 335 and that
money that you got in the morning those
you know fifteen sixteen dollars was the
grocery money for the week and to go to
Pathmark I think in West Haven or
wherever we went to Pathmark
there was only one guy on the food that
had a car we were all so nice to him
because now it's cheaper than buying
groceries you know on Temple Street not
Temple Lord now whatever that Street was
parallel to then and so these are very
tough times I mean I think all the
values weren't learned about being
careful with your money was learned at
the time when I was at Sol because I
didn't have money hmm especially the
first year being dead broke was a great
learning experience now we have all
these grants and loans and things it's a
bigger support system it is a bigger
scale is a much more International does
definite it was it's one of the things
president xi really has done there which
has been really quite quite wonderful
so Indra talking about international
matters I when again when we spoke last
time you said you were thinking about
moving a board meeting to someplace
overseas we do it every two years and so
tell me about that is that something
that you started to help where do where
do you go so it's it's a normal
procedure
most companies but I think it's a bad
idea tell you why I think board meeting
shouldn't be held overseas I think we
should have international trips by the
board but board meetings themselves have
so many
the requirements in a comp committee
audit committee you're nominating
committee you've got to go through
procedural stuff and when you're
jet-lagged going through those mounds of
paper and flying over your auditors your
comm consultants your executives so
don't need to be part of about me it's
just not a good use of time so the big
lesson I've learned is that board
meetings should always be held in a time
zone where jet lag is not going to be a
factor so somewhere between Dallas and
New York and just stay with that
especially I'm an older boy it's very
hard okay and if you're going to do
international trips make those strict
international trips so you can do it on
your own schedule not necessarily tied
to a board schedule so how much of your
time are you in the States versus
looking around the rest of your
operations was it 50/50 and your family
how is that then you know that's another
of these gender dishes no Indra has
never children and yet has had a very
ambitious career pretty much from
leaving here have you managed that it's
not very well I say that because you
know the good news bad news is that my
children don't know what it is to have a
stay-at-home mom I had to stay at home
mom it was fantastic
my kids don't know what it is to have a
stay-at-home mom if I come home at 4
p.m. and my daughter comes home from
school she says mom is everything ok did
you lose your job it's a very different
mindset because they've never seen mom
at home that's the good news and the bad
news so they don't know what it is to
you know have mom greeting them the door
with a snack and the house smelling like
the good stuff has been made none of
that stuff
they come home to a nanny at home ok and
so I'd say in those parts are the
traditional definition of a good mom I
wouldn't say I've been a good mom being
a role model giving them experiences
they've never had taking them places
giving them access to all kinds of
mind-blowing experiences sure I've made
all of
possible I think the person that has a
toughest especially if in today's world
I hope it changes before you guys become
CEOs is if you're married to somebody
like me how do you cope with it it's not
easy it is not easy because you go to a
party or a dinner I go with my husband
and we walk in and at the end of dinner
see him again so for the three hours
that we're at the dinner been on the
same table I don't know where he is
I'm talking to all kinds of people and
if I don't people say she's too
standoffish so I'm shaking hands taking
pictures and the end of dinner I'm
looking fun because he's my ride home
he looks at me and he goes why do I come
to the event because I don't even enjoy
it I have to dress up like a penguin you
know put on his black tie he said why am
i coming to these events I go because I
knew married me I realized that maybe
put it the other way women always
accepted it you know the same thing
happened to women too when they were
wives they just accepted it because
Society said that's the norm for the
woman to just be nice smile and chitchat
with some other women about coupons and
kids but for men they didn't do that I
mean other times I give you we go to
dinners and I'm sitting between two men
who might be world leaders and having
the time of my life having a great
conversation my husband meanwhile is
sitting between two women were all great
people but they have nothing of interest
to him so he's not making up
conversation to have with him he does a
fantastic job I mean this is I married a
keeper I mean he does a great job but I
tell you I would have a tough time being
married to me there's not easy it is not
easy well at least on your children my
daughter often says she's grateful that
I raised her with such low standards
because she doesn't have to feel guilty
when she goes and has her career
so just think about it that way so let
us return to business I'm gonna ask one
more question then we'll open the floor
for a little bit of time so we're in a
recession I see very happily you've
hired some of my students I'm just very
pleased with that
how how is how is the recession
affecting your businesses you're in a
wide range of different businesses
restaurants beverage a little in Watsons
long time lots of lots of stuff freedom
all kinds of things so how is it
affecting different pieces there's no
question that in the developed world and
I say Western Europe Eastern Europe and
North America we are in a tremendous
downtown there's no question about it
any which way you look at it it's
impacting consumers in a significant way
there's an age of thrift people are
afraid to spend money and people are
being very careful about what they shop
for and where they shop for and when
they shop we've never seen people make
lists for groceries as they do now
everything is a planned purchase in the
past they'd go to a single grocery store
and buy whatever they wanted now they
are willing to make three grocery store
trips to even get the best value so
pricing is going to be very critical the
other thing is being very carefully
watched us if somebody wants to spend $5
on beverages not $5.99 or $6.99 as they
used to before they mentally say I'm
going to spend $5.00 on beverages so how
you do price pack in architecture to
make sure you give them the right
package size for certain dollar outlay
is becoming a more important factor than
just saying what's the price of a
24-pack beverage package so we have to
think differently about the consumer and
how they shop when they get their
paycheck versus the middle of the month
or the week after the paycheck the
patterns are totally different so how
you promote and deal in the different
windows has to change now the good news
is
whether the economy's up or down people
still have to eat and drink and they say
that in this down economy people are
renting more DVDs not even going to
movie theaters the rental DVD rentals
have gone through the roof they're
renting more DVDs staying home you know
drinking their diet Pepsi and eating
their Doritos and having a good time
ok so business is okay but let me tell
you where we see the soft underbelly
convenience stores used to be the place
which was a leading indicator of the
economy because your construction worker
your alley worker got up in the morning
pulled up in a convenience store bought
a six-pack of Mountain Dew and four bags
of Doritos put it in the pickup truck
and went to the construction site that
construction worker doesn't exist in
many many parts of the country so that
until that hourly worker and that
construction worker jobs come back the
foundation of the economy is not strong
so we need to get that going again the
second thing is we've talked to
convenience store retailers who have ATM
machines in the sea store and they look
at the the drawers every week and if you
look at the withdrawals consumers are
coming in and withdrawing $10 at a time
and paying $1 75 service charge drawing
$10 at a time just to shop in a
convenience store for just what they
need for the week because they'd only
want to go to a big grocery store and
their balances tend to be $20 which is a
huge change from two years ago so these
are the leading indicators that are very
worrisome and we need to find a way to
get you know over the next 2-3 years two
or three million low-end jobs back in
you know the real workhorse jobs back in
to get the economy moving again we have
an hour pill battle in front of us is
anyone from our administration talking
to you oh yes all the time so I know
these days part of the CEOs job is
dealing with the public sector yeah do
you have a favorite thing than doing
lately no be there all the time in fact
from here I go to Washington we have
dinner with the president tonight but
Te'o's they're talking with us all the
time all the time I mean last night we
had a wonderful dinner with Peter Orszag
the head of the Office of Management
budget going through pieces on the
budget so being a CEO today
Washington's very very open to our ideas
the issue is whatever ideas CEOs give
politically can you sell it we've never
seen such a partisan environment so
politically can you sell it so the big
question is it's not the ideas it's how
do you get Washington to accept it and
act on it and I think they like this is
where democracy works against us so yeah
but you know again as you remember it is
one of the things we've always done is
to seriously the public process as well
as the nonprofit and the for-profit
world and I think these days seems like
that's even more important